T
SOUR FHE AWER.
COMPYHAT PVISRILLGEO A
AND PDUCTN SERCESO U.
OILOMPANIES A AHORF
POWED ECTRIAR DANVERY
HARD
AL RHT,AN, HOW DIFFILT I
THAT OIL OUTROUND A G
HURDLES.P TOUGH T OF
RO BLOCK LE SAMANRUP
DINNER O TO T DARTMT O
TERI
>>HERE HASEFINELY BEE A
SWIT FRO THE TRUADNISTTION TO EN
MINIRATI.
FEEL LEHEYUS KP
ANDEEPRYIN TO,OU KW,
HO THE INDTRYACKND KP
FRO CKINGHAT WE DOVERY
Y.
>>esse: DOHEYVERAL YOU
GUYS O THEHONE AAY HEY,
YS,HERICEF G IOW
MOST.50 DO THE SAYEY,
MAYBEOU CLD HP U O?
>>O,UITE THE OPPOSITBU I WLELL Y
UPSEE WHE TYALK ABO
KN ITHEIL FIE WHICHLE I
SUPPTS ABOUT 1MILLN JS
THE U.S., TYOR HAR
WE GET DIR, WORK VY, VER
AND NOT THA EASY SOMETIM.
AN TO JUS HEAHESE PPLE
FR J PSA FROMHE WTE
HOE PODIU YOU KNO GN
AND ONBOUT,0 LSES AND
DOEST KNOW T DIFRENCE
BEEE A LEA AND A PERTS
COMEEEHATE D EVERY DAY
LEASE ANDERMINC BETEN A
>>esseTHATHOD B A
TALKG PNT.
JOB,ND IT' A DGEUS JOBY
AND SS TINGOAKE Y
YS O  BE W PFITES.
PREDE BID WERE
LLINTO D O PT.
WE C DINITYNCREE
ERICRODUCTIO
ASK TEXAS ASK NOR DAKA.ASKG VENE
WE CAN DOTERE WH AMECAN
JO.
BUUST T OU OF OURAY.
LE USAVE THEIPELES TO
GETHE, YOUNOW, PMITS
THROH.
OP TKING NSENS ABO
WHATOU A TALKING ABOUT.
JUST GETUTF OUR W.
CO ITERE.
ANDE CAN PUS T PCE DOW
D PDUCE ME OILIG HE
IN AMERICA
T'S UEA AMECA'SNERG
D D IT RIGHT HER RIGOW.
>>esseBI GOTUT O THE
WAYN THEORDE
ITEEMS LIKE HEHOD G O
OF T W HE IN TEXND
THANK Y SOUCH FOR JOING
US.